Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be speaking
with Alexandra Hudson, who's an award winning
journalist, author and speaker, as well as
the founder of Civic Renaissance. Her new
book is Against Politeness, Why Politeness
Failed America and How Civility Can Save It.
It's so great having you on. I really appreciate
it.
Speaker 2: Thanks, David, for having me.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, I think to start with,
we should talk about the difference between
politeness and civility. There's so much discussion,
particularly in modern politics, about why
many people aren't civil or can we continue
to be civil versus politeness, which is really
something different. So maybe let's start
there. Like what are these two different concepts?
Speaker 2: It's a it's a good question, and
that's that's that's the core thesis of my
forthcoming book that there is this difference.
But I think a lot of people today fail to
recognize what a difference we use. These
two terms civility and politeness interchangeably.
And that makes it difficult to think, OK,
what do we want less of in society and what
do we want more of? Because people today,
they either longed for more civility, more
politeness they longed for these days of gentility
and chivalry. And I think society is going
to hell in a handbasket or they want less
of point as they think that it's not they
what they think. It's civility. That tool
of white supremacy, a tool of social oppression,
a tool of social injustice. So I argue that
by making this distinction, we can again have
more clarity about what we're talking about.
We want what we want. So I argue that politeness
is a technique. It's manners, it's the superficial
expression of social norms and etiquette.
Civility, by contrast, is a disposition. It's
a way of looking at others and the world and
seeing other people as as human beings just
like us with equal moral worth and with beings,
with dignity and worth and worthy of respect.
And the etymology of these two terms supports
that distinction. The root word of politeness
is the Latin word polar year, which means
to smooth or polished, and that's what politeness
does. Again, it focuses on the external whereas
civility. But the Latin root is tinnitus or
TiVo's, which is city or citizen and civility
connotes the conduct befitting a member of
the city or a serious of the duties of citizenship.
So I think it's important to make these distinction
to know what do we want more of a lot less
up in society.
Speaker 1: For many people, they might be
thinking about these concepts in the context
of conversations they have with, you know,
their uncle at Thanksgiving or whatever the
case may be. Can you kind of apply this to
such interpersonal conversations and give
us examples of how civility and politeness
can overlap? But also one can exist absent
the other and kind of what that would look
like in human interaction?
Speaker 2: Absolutely. I'm of the mind that
this is of civility is actually the truly
respectful way of engaging with others because
it's seeing people as human beings first with
equal moral worth. So what? Whereas politeness
would want to smooth over differences? Civility
says I respect you enough, David, to tell
you when I think you're terribly wrong on
a subject, I'm not going to patronize you
and just smile when I think that you're incorrect.
I'm going to tell you what I think that's
that truly respectful thing to do, however.
And again, that's what a democracy requires.
It requires having being able to have robust,
honest discourse and not just suppressing
discussion or papering over important differences.
However, I will note that not all contexts
in life are the same. You know, having a debate
in a college classroom or on the floors of
a Congress is different than having a dinner
with your family member. And I'm a firm believer
that politics has taken too much of our consciousness,
and our psyche is too much a part of our lives.
And there are way more important things in
politics, such as relationships with family
members. And I don't think that you have to
fight to the death on every single political
issue. It's too easy to let political issues
come between relationships and family family
family relationships these days. And so I
think it's perfectly fine to say, you know
what, we're not going to talk about x y z
issue or I could talk about politics at all
because because we're talking about other
things, you know, our kids or, you know, our
lives because this relationship matters more
than focusing on the sore spots, the areas
of disagreement that may not be reconcilable
right now.
Speaker 1: Yes, sometimes viewers will call
me and they'll say, Hey, you know, like, for
example, a left wing viewer will call and
say, When I go back to wherever during college
break, you know, my parents have turned into
the opposite of what I am. They watch Fox
News all day and they think Joe Biden lost,
and they think the vaccines turn you into
a turtle and you know, all these different
things. How can I change their mind? And and
my answer always is, well, what? What are
you willing to allow to happen to your relationship
with them? Because I can, I could. Answer
in terms of how mines are sometimes changed,
but part of it is, are you willing to not
have a relationship with them anymore? Or
you need to figure that out first, so to speak,
and it seems that that is missing sometimes
from just figuring out how can I have my ideas
win over someone is someone else's.
Speaker 2: And I think that's reflective of
this mentality in our political discourse
today, where it's all zero-sum. It's like
I have to win and I'm going to win at all
costs. It's like, you know, scorched earth
policy. And you can't take that logic and
apply it to our relationships and our family
and our family context. I don't think that's
the right thing to do and be, and that's not
the right thing to do. Generally, you can't
have a democracy with that sort of scorched,
scorched earth zero-sum mindset. That's part
of my part. The conclusion of my book argues
that again, we we suffer from a crisis of
misplaced meaning in our society today, where
these traditional touchstones family, civil
society church, these are all kind of on the
respondent and in recent years and and politics
has become the place where we derive our meaning
from, which is why, which is why every political
issue cuts us to our core. If someone disagrees
with that, it's like we're being personally
assaulted and we go into fight or flight mode
as opposed to if we had these other driver
meaning from other places, we could have kind
of the equanimity of spirit to be able to
have these difficult conversations. But we've
allowed politics to matter too much to us,
which is why it's difficult to have these
conversations.
Speaker 1: Well, before we move on to the
more like governmental level application of
this to keep it at the personal a little bit,
there are no doubt people who were. We'll
hear this conversation and they'll say, Well,
you know, guys, Alexandra David, there are
circumstances where it's not that I'm looking
for a fight, but I cannot be civil nor polite
with people who, for example, if I were gay
and I know that their I'm around people, whether
it's parents or coworkers or whatever, who
quite literally believe that I'm going to
hell, I'm an evil person or whatever. Something
so fundamental to what I am and who I am.
It's not that I'm trying to make political
disagreements the forefront, but I can't be
civil with someone who sees me in that way.
It's very easy to say, let's not make it all
about politics we don't have. But when it's
something so core to who I am, I can't be
civil. I can't be polite. It's not possible.
There's validity to that as well, isn't there?
Speaker 2: Of course, and I absolutely empathize
with that position, I would, however, point
people of that mindset to a really powerful
example of someone who lives out, lives out
decency with people that that that he disagrees
with, to say the least that day. Jazz musician
Daryl Davis. If you haven't heard of him,
he's
Speaker 1: been on the show. Yeah.
Speaker 2: Awesome. Yeah, exactly. His his
story is incredible where he he, he makes,
you know, makes it his personal mission in
life to win over white supremacists who literally
think he's a subhuman and he does it through
conversation and kindness and relationship.
No one's ever been persuaded to change their
mind about anything by being insulted and
like, hit over the head with with rationality
and arguments. And he really embodies the
ethos of saying, You know, I'm going to see
the personhood pass the bigotry, and I'm going
to try and reach that and focus on what we
have in common. And he's changed a lot of
hearts and minds that way. It's a really powerful
example for each of us.
Speaker 1: It's what he does is really incredible
when it comes to national and world level
politics. Are there some examples of of when
politeness led to bad outcomes or results
that we could talk through?
Speaker 2: Well, politeness across history
has been this tool of division. It's been
it's been a way of signifying the in-group
and the outgroup both countries, both within
and between countries and within a given society.
It's been a way for people to feel superior
to others. In ancient Greece, for example,
they anyone who didn't speak Greek and have
the manners of of Greek people were were called
barbarians. That's where we get our word barbarian
from its when someone it means someone who
basically doesn't speak Greek. And for the
Greeks, they didn't leave it as, OK, they
just speak a different language and they have
different manners than us. For them, they
said, OK, they're different from us. Therefore,
they're morally inferior and they're less
like they're lesser than us. And that logic,
that kind of thinking is not unique to the
ancient Greeks. We see that all across culture,
all across history and even through to today
in the American Gilded Age, for example, to
a fabulous new HBO show called The Gilded
Age that I'm loving right now every Monday
night. And that's a great example of of how
manners and social norms and politeness was
weaponized to keep the nouveau riche, the
parvenus, the Rockefellers and the Carnegies.
They were the new boat riche. They're the
names that we remember now, but they were
the outgroup. They were the ones that the
old money and society wanted to keep out.
And so Emily Emily, Vanderbilt's big tome
on etiquette and Emily post as well. Those
are all etiquette books on, you know, handbooks
for how to be a social elite that actually
the middle class and immigrants who came to
America started reading and saying, Oh my
gosh, this is what it means to be an American,
and they kind of help them assimilate. It
was kind of a shorthand for how to how to
do this thing called life together. So what
originally started as this project of exclusion
ended up being a way to invite and welcome
the newcomer into society?
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's interesting. I've
heard from people who did not grow up necessarily
with parents that were able to inform them
of of a lot of kind of social norms and etiquette
stuff to talk about. I got into college and
then the job fairs, and they realized at a
certain point when they would get to either
these group interviews or different things.
It wasn't that they were less able or knowledgeable
when it came to the subject matter, but they
realized they didn't know all the social norms,
even when things things as simple as when
everybody sits at a table to a meal. And there's
sort of like a pecking order in terms of like,
were the people doing the hiring? Were the
people. And they knew they were at a disadvantage
specifically for those reasons.
Speaker 2: Absolutely. I think too often we
assume we know someone's character, you know,
their inner state, by the shorthand, by manners,
whether they know which fork to use and again,
how the norms of politeness have been weaponized
across human history. And part of my argument
with my for my book is we need to focus less
on those the trimmings, you know, focus less
on the etiquette and more on the timeless
principles of civility that have served us
well in this project of human community across
time and place. I argue that, you know, civility
is not a new problem. It's not an America
problem. It's not a now problem. It is a human
problem, which is why every single society
without fail across history has had etiquette
books as a whole, and they've had social norms
that help us do this thing called life together.
It's hard. Society and civilization is fragile
and it takes work. And if we're not all doing
this together or not, we're not all part of
this thing called society together. It's going
to fall apart. And we've seen, like we have,
we're watching, you know, civilization fell
apart in the Ukraine right now and we weren't
where it is is very much a part of of our
world today, and we can't take that for granted.
We have to remember the rule that we each
have in supporting this. This thing called
a free system. Already, this thing called
democracy and this thing called human community,
Speaker 1: hey, when it comes to someone like
Donald Trump, you know, the the making fun
of a disabled reporter and the thing Rosie
O'Donnell I don't remember as a dog or is
fat or whatever, you know, all the coarse
language and all that stuff did. Did Trump
change expectations of politeness or civility
in politics?
Speaker 2: I think that's an interesting question.
There is no doubt that he he did, of course,
in our public discourse in a lot of ways.
But his his two things. I think his hits the
crassness of his language, the candor. I think
a lot of people saw that as truth telling.
That was the, you know, people saw that as,
OK, he's being honest and civil. People are
sick of the politeness, the veneer that the
political correctness, people are sick of
being suppressed and you know, the language
police and that was going on. He cut through
the hypocrisy of all that. And I think that
appealed to a lot of people, which is kind
of what I make the argument that we need to
care less about the form of care, less about
the politeness and more about civility, the
honest truth telling that we need for democracy.
So I think he tapped into a really important
insight that people have been sensing and
intuiting for a really long time. But secondly,
it is really important that to realize that
Donald Trump did not create our civility problem
again, this is not a new problem, not an America
problem. It's a human problem. It's been a
challenge to human. So I argue in my book
that as human beings, we are profoundly social.
We thrive. We become fully human and community,
but we're also profoundly selfish and self-interested.
We aim to meet our needs before others were
just biologically morally driven that way.
And and those two things are always intention.
They always have been and always will be.
So there's there's never going to be a permanent
solution to the civility challenge in our
world today. And there never has been. But
but what we can do is look to the wisdom of
the past, look to how thoughtful people have
have have have have advised that we overcome
this tension before and help us live live
well together.
Speaker 1: The forthcoming book is Against
Politeness, Why Politeness Failed America
and How Civility Can Save It. We've been speaking
with the author, Alexandra Hudson, an award
winning, award winning journalist, author
and speaker. Really appreciate your time and
your insights today.
Speaker 2: Thanks so much for having me, David.